good morning good morning garden Wow
Sunday
you look incredible thank you sir I feel
crap I do I feel liberated to be honest
with you Oh with the fresh shave new
haircut I feel amazing they feel like a
million dollars feel like what I spend
on my end what you guys think of your
new innkeeper look papa innkeeper and an
owner right when I first arrived I drove
into the Four Seasons Inn but this
establishment is a one-off it's not part
of a chain right so you deserve your
name your own identity and something
that you can be proud of everybody is
gonna know you now as Layla's Riverside
Lodge is amazing the names awesome the
sun's beautiful it's just screams me
what do you think I think it's
absolutely perfect and represent
something so meaningful to Sandy yep see
right okay yeah sure I'm positive
yeah what do you think we go sides love
to this is the new reception area have a
look at this
[Music]
so let's welcome I guess in to a proper
a reception area
this is inviting this is war I love it
is it lovely gorgeous if you have an
inviting lounge then you need the menu
to go with it
gents come through please I've created a
farm-to-table menu of fresh food that
will give people a warm and friendly
Vermont welcome I've revamp the entire
menu
let me tell you about some of my
favorites homemade country pate
I mean look where we are look at the
farm surrounding the inn how do you not
have a stunning country pate wonderful
poutine done with the braised pork
shoulder stunning chicken potpie easy to
execute for the kitchen bates
job done and then I was telling Vermont
cheesecake how you feeling very hopeful
for the future now are you happier now
that sandy is out of the kitchen I am
absolutely ecstatic that city is out of
the kitchen the menu is absolutely
perfect all right now don't be shy
before when people asked me where i
worked i used to hang my head and say
the four seasons
i'm not gonna do that no more i can look
him right in the eye and say work at
Layla's
[Music]
it's gonna be good I'm delighted they
like the new name a new menu I can't
wait to see what they think of the
bedrooms
Oh God
is that hideous wallpaper replaced with
a stunning wooden feature we have
steamed the carpet so go on of those
hideous stains we have a luxury bed for
the dog and what I was more depressed
with than anything was the linen was
hideous we have replaced the bedding in
every room of your in with a hundred
thousand dollars of organic Linens ah
yappy yappy Goswami
[Music]
welcome to the thing that makes your
Lodge unique a new and improved dog
kennel amazing I'm stunned we doubled
the size of these kennels we've made
them feel luxurious
we have beautiful brand-new bedding when
I first arrived these kennels felt like
a prison now it feels like a reward or a
treat any dog lover want their dogs to
stay even me I'd bring my whole doctor
Joanna Joanna me triple Rum Pum call me
Layla
look how gorgeous now this part for me
is one of those exciting parts come this
way please come in I've never seen the
kennel with that many dogs and that many
people that many smiles the dogs are
here because we've organized their dog
agility competition Oh No kidding
Wow all the owners are movie check-in
and staying in the end perceiving this
kind of event can't be done every month
which will drive dog refused us to come
a stay in your stunning Lodge sounds
amazing
mm-hmm so we will live in the place up
giving it Walt
yes and Sandy this is Shannon Hagen you
may recognize this lady it's a girl she
is a luxury boarding kennel consultant
she has very kindly donated to you
$10,000 worth of consultancy that she's
gonna help implement and get this
business off the ground yeah really good
job deep and do not let him back in this
kitchen no sir no rice tough one we had
our highs and lows but you are really
starting to grasp ya abstention one not
surprised
everybody's going on pair
tomorrow everybody they're all gonna
have a paycheck every week really yes
that's music to my ears I'm pleased to
hear it listen good luck thank you so
take care of hey Joe
[Music]
good morning Layla's Riverside Lodge
since my visits business at Layla's has
been booming and everyone is sharing in
the in success it's 500 bucks tomorrow
w-2 how you rock okay thank we got a
great team and you're part of it
my staff beeps the world to me every
week you get paid is it's a team effort
you've got to have people that believe
in you everybody can you get a paycheck
thank you thank you thank you Gordon
from the bottom of my heart
whoops I hadn't been for you I would not
be here
[Music]
thank you